c'est un fabuleux trésor 13 millions de
mètres cube d'or liquide alimenté par
une petite rivière le rhin la fierté des
élus de champagney mais même un jour de
pluie ils sont bien placés pour rappeler
qu'il faut se méfier de l'eau qui dort
les anciens de champagne et vous diront
que le niveau de l'eau sont très bas
cette année le rhin étaient à sec mais
complètement assez pour la première fois
et les personnes qui ont des puits sur
leurs habitations se sont rendus compte
aussi que les puits on en voyait
aujourd'hui le fond et que la ressource
était en perdition
au point que cette année le syndicat des
eaux a dû fermer quelques vannes si les
9000 abonnés du secteur ont pu être
approvisionnés héricourt commune
pourtant cliente a dû se faire livrer
par camions depuis montbéliard alors
quand les élus ont appris par une fuite
ça ne s'invente pas que belfort avait
commandé une étude pour un raccordement
futur ça a été la goutte d'eau faire
remonter de l'eau jusque dans le
territoire est plus compliqué que de la
faire descendre sur les courts presque
plus légitime ou raccordement mais
surtout champagne est fier de la rigueur
de sa gestion ne veut pas avoir à se
rationner pour une agglomération qui
pourraient consommer sans compter un
ressources elle est ici au montage de la
gérer au mieux on la protège également
je veux dire c'est qu'il faut pas voir
l'eau que comme un bien de consommation
c'est aussi tout un écosystème donc
attention aux raccourcis de dire voilà
il ya 13 millions de mètres cubes d'eau
ici bas il nous en faut trois ou quatre
on les prend et puis on restera bien
assez faut surtout regarder la ressource
dans sa vision globale
on ne peut pas concevoir qu'une ville
comme belfort de monde de l'eau alors
qu'ici on n'est pas sûr de pouvoir
approvisionner tous les gens avec qui on
s'est engagé au niveau du syndicat dont
on est tous d'accord pour se mettre
autour de la table regarder la manière
intelligente de partager cette ressource
très cher quelques lots le bassin de son
panier c'est un peu la réserve des
fourmis qui intéresse les cigales qu'en
adviendra-t-il aux temps chauds de la
disette le grand belfort communiquera
t-il bientôt les résultats de sa
mystérieuse enquête à nous en tout cas
ne nous déplaisent il n'a rien voulu
dire